good luck
we love you i love you too jane galt
welcome back
opponent taking
a strangely long time on g3
like usually
maybe not usually but very often white
pre-moves bishop g2
a good thing i didn't try the lefong
oh
d5 is probably the most principled move
i mean usually against like knight of
three kings union attack i play
um more of a queen's gambit decline
setup
but
i think it makes sense to control the
center
ah swight's going for hippo
i'll start with knight c6
so when bishop b2 comes upon's already
defended
and
i can play bishop
bishop e6
i might go for this
what you call it english attack setup
i might throw in this move too
yeah might as well
because if white plays h4 then then the
pawn can't move backwards
i can go for
um like this maneuver
here i think i'll play f6
yeah white's still kind of employing a
hippo
64 crew asking
advice on alvin counter gabbit
i don't play the album too often
it's playable though
not sure what like general advice i can
give
castle queen side here and there's also
bishop h3
[Music]
immediately
there's also this move
i think i'll play a5
so it's unclear where white wants to
castle
castling queen side i'll already be
ready to attack
c4 oh huh
white showing noof here
can play a3
a3
[Music]
there's also takes
i was also considering bishop b4
i have a choice to make here
i think i'll start with a3
ideas after bishop b4 or bishop c3 i
played bishop b4 and if we trade then d3
could be a target
i'll be threatening this and if castling
then i can start attacking
i should also complete development at
some point too
yeah with album of course you should
like know the main traps
um
but then beyond that
i think the same advice can be applied
to any opening is like use the master's
database
find games with strong players or even
leachate's database
and see
kind of how the
top players develop in the middle game
especially in the lines where white
doesn't fall into a trap
i think the opening is objectively
dubious
but you're not going to be losing even
if white knows what they're doing
i guess one issue with the albin is if
white plays knight f3 on move two
you can't play an alvin
so white could avoid it and then you
have to
learn some kind of like queen's gambit
declined accepted semi slav
terrace
okay
so white defended c2 but left d3 hanging
so this worked out pretty nicely
i could go for takes
it makes sense
opening the d file
queen supports the knight now
and there's some like rook d8
i don't want to leave a3 undefended
and i don't want to like play this and
cause my rook to be a target
i'm considering this move actually
all looks kind of interesting
knight b2
because we trade
we trade again
let's do it
it seems like i'm going in the wrong
direction
but this is forcing some simplification
and there's a line like takes
let's say king takes takes takes and the
a file opens
even if like gives a check in that line
a2 is still vulnerable
[Music]
like if a4 i take on b3
this looks fun
ziggy p says i feel like most queen's
gambit players are way way booked up
on more qj qja or qgd
that's probably a true statement
yeah there is an element of
surprise value when it comes to openings
oh white was prepared
okay so i think i'll trade and then play
c6
undermine the bishop defend the pawn
[Music]
hey it's gotham
what's up gotham
shout out to levy
we had uh
i think we still have yeah we still have
64 crew in the chat
i was explaining the the history of crew
64
a little bit earlier
okay the king wants to high now the
knight wants to develop
and the other rook wants to come in
i see the comment from edu fun chasse on
youtube
hey eric i played abu dhabi event 2 saw
you surrounded by fans
for a pick
just a minute before the round
yeah uh
i took a lot of fan photos
in abu dhabi
had to sign a lot of things welcome back
from abu dhabi i enjoyed your recap of
your games oh thank you multimorph
okay so i'm up upon i don't think i need
to do anything too special
just go for the rook train
i think sometimes when it's knight
versus bishop
is this the eric bartholomew channel
love your work
um
maybe it's
maybe someday i can change my
last name to bartholomew
but uh
john is a big inspiration
good to have your streams back again
missed you while you were gone what did
you eat in abu dhabi
i had a lot of food it was like hotel
buffet every day for every meal
it was good
i had a lot of hummus and baba ganduje
and pita
there's different types of curry and
soup every day taboola
had a lot of taboola
okay so this bishop is
kind of just sad for life now
which makes me happy for life the plan
is to play knight c6 to b4
i don't think it's possible for the king
and rook to attack the pawn
at once
because if the king ever comes to b3
then um it blocks a rook
the question is how do i make progress
and walk up with the king
maybe i could sack
oh maybe i just control
and so only open vial so i might as well
control
it looking at the line bishop h3 g6
king takes a3 and then
either rook d2 or rook 8 i'll win the a2
pawn
[Music]
and white's pieces are just a little bit
stuck here
there is one day they had pizza in the
buffet
and i had it
it was decent
i think i'll play this move
and this would have been more forcing
but this move i think it'll drain more
time from white
and it basically does the same thing
oh there's a funny line
king b5 b6
and now mate is unstoppable
the black pieces just want to hug the
light king
from all directions
the most loving setup on the queen side
did you play in the last lechas arena
i did
um but i was i was at the airport i
really wanted to stream it
but i just
i didn't quite have my stream set up in
place and the wi-fi was questionable
but i was at um i was in some kind of
airport lounge
at the dubai airport
i was doing pretty well in the
tournament
like i was
top 20 or top 30 for a while
[Music]
okay
that's nice gained a point
thanks for the game tune aldo
[Music]
yeah white was trying to play like a
solid opening
and then i mean queen d1 was a turning
point
i think castling and
[Music]
it's not clear if i'm actually better
i could guess the eval
[Music]
eric any jet lag
black is still better
yeah i guess it's still pleasant i have
more space
nice pawn in e3
uh yeah i am jet lagged i woke up at
like 4 30
this morning
but i have some energy
i got a smoothie
i went to this new juice place
that opened next to the chess club
and they were promoting like these juice
cleanses so i might do a juice cleanse
sometime this week
to just cleanse myself from all the food
i ate in abu dhabi
welcome back eric enjoyed your
tournament re-recaps a lot
the usual b
is this just me or does it mispronounce
recaps
there's been a couple of times where it
feels like it said re-recaps welcome
back
and thanks for all the game re-recaps
am i hallucinating
wait
one more time also thank you irv
welcome back
and thanks for all the game re-recaps
it's saying re-recaps right
but you spelled it normally you spell it
recaps
i wonder why it's doing that
a re-recap is when you do a recap again
glad to see you back
but a recap is just when you cap again
i think
no cap what does no cap mean
hear that a lot these days
wait
hector bat says recap stands for
recapitulate
really
a summary of what has been said
a recapitulation oh wow
recapitulate i didn't know that
but that's a verb
so the noun is recapitulation
go where'd my thing go
whoa it's two of me
it's a weird thing on windows 10 when
you shake it
it goes away and then enjoy your content
your re-recaps were great while you were
away from streaming quack
can you leave the arena around you too
early
i think you are referring to this
tournament is this tournament as a swiss
not an arena
but if you leave early then i think you
just get zero points for those rounds
that you miss
it'll be seven rounds total
hey it's bob eight months let's go let's
go
hey it's a karo khan
so i'm playing the two knights attack
following my prep
from the
crush the caro khan video
this is also my prep for levy
this is also my prep for joe bava
because joe bava usually plays carol
khan and i was uh
preparing for him
in the tournament
oh my queen oh no
ah
this is still theory
main move is this
and then queenie two
actually haven't looked at this line in
a while
at first it doesn't look so impressive
for black
but um
i think this is a topical variation
there is some game in the world cup uh
farouza against cinderella
they played a very
like deep theoretical line here but i
think that game featured b5
d4 makes sense
and castling
yeah nothing too special
just developing
[Music]
it's useful to get bishop c4 and then
queen e2
uh because the piece is harmonized
better and i provoke e6 so this bishop
is kind of sad
and i have a bit more space with the
d-pawn
easy development
i mean black wants to do something like
this this but c6 hangs
so feeling good already
knight t5
that's a fine move
trying to understand what black wants to
do but i think black just prevented me
from
actively developing the bishop
so
yeah i mean i could play c3
it's typical improving
i move c3 makes some sense hi eric glad
to see you back again
thanks for the tournament games on
stream
oh thank you
peter holland
oh and shout out to bob too also shout
out to diamond cutter
hello streamers
b5
yeah i want to take the pawn but then
does it work
there's queen c7
[Music]
it looks a little bit risky to take
just with the h pawn
[Music]
bishop's still hanging
i mean i should calculate knight c6
so queen h5 g3
queen c7 i take on b5 take on h2 king h1
so i'm looking at this line
and bishop b7 it seems like black gets a
decent compensation
and bishop d3 just seems way more
controlled
oh shout out to levy too who was briefly
here earlier
up and coming chess streamer and
youtuber
i've f4
and black wants to play c5 eventually
so f4 is one choice
queen h5
queen h5 g6 queen h6
i'm taking time here
i'm trying to figure out the best path
queen g4
[Music]
there's some idea like
i think i should start with queen h5
black has an option black has this this
or f5
i actually thought that f5 was the least
likely
um because now bishop g5 comes with
tempo
an e6 is a
long-term weakness
a backward pawn
on the half open file
i don't mind the queen trade like queen
either probably trade
although i could move back to
play queen e2
maybe queen e2
and queen g6
how to do this
i think i'll go with my first my first
intuition was to take
i think that's simpler
if i were to retreat somehow the queen
would maybe at some point come in
and
i don't mind playing a more positional
game here
so i have nice control over the square
this would be an attempt to trap the
bishop
at 4 i could play f3
and then
get the bishop back to f2 eventually
if h6
probably have to play bishop d2
welcome back to jimberwood
and cdr siri
yeah i'm careful about language but also
my moves
i feel like sometimes after i play a
tournament i
like it causes me to change my style in
some way
like be more cautious during games
it's like during serious tournament
games
especially when i'm playing good players
i get in the habit of like double
checking triple checking every line
because you just have so much more time
and
it becomes a habit just to
be a bit more cautious
there's more pressure in the classical
games
i think c4 makes a lot of sense
c4c5
fix the pawn
the drawback is if i place e5 uh gives
away the d5 square
and it kind of forces some
transformation though
that's a reasonable end game like c5
takes takes
[Music]
and there is rook d8
finally got a baby badge
welcome back eric congratulations quack
from what i thought you were gonna say
finally got a baby but
baby badge is maybe the first step
okay i can't spend all my time here
i don't think c5 is good though
me a3
f4
there's f3
[Music]
and go play
f3 it's a slower move
but the pawn is very useful in f3 just
restricting the minor pieces
also gives my bishop a square eventually
something some question about
advice for beginners about nervous
okay let me let me try and answer that
after this game
um
because time is running low
i want to make sure i'm not uh
getting too low position still tends to
yeah so if rook d8 i think i played
bishop f1
[Music]
hibernate the light squared bishop
and this bishop is temporarily
undefended
but i'm not seeing any like great
discoveries
takes i take
i'm ready to play rook d1
some c5 idea
b3 probably makes sense at some point
oh also this move which i maybe should
have considered
i guess black had takes and then rook d2
interesting
[Music]
really close to winning material
okay let me try this
and then bishop b6 if
okay if hero there is takes
with check
if i'm preventing this and i'm preparing
c5
rook is tied down to defending the
bishop
bishops pin to the the rook so neither
of these pieces can move
i'm also threatening to win the pawn
so we might see something like rookie 7
but then i can still push take and then
take
or even push take in bishop c4
or just take on a5
so this is looking pretty good
rooks are well positioned
all of these things are targets
time is leveling out
oh yes i am back in the u.s
i was in abu dhabi for a couple weeks
i got back yesterday afternoon
i'm just realizing did i just miss c5
bishop b5
that may have been even simpler
yeah i think if i saw it i would have
played it
okay but now c5 it's um
a simple pin and win
i'm also threatening bishop v5 so might
be multiple ways to win material
i did not fly business class
to fly business class i would need
i would need a lot more subscribers on
twitch
maybe someday though
i have been accumulating some like
airline miles all the travels
yeah speaking of uh if you have prime
you could sub for free
and support the channel
i do appreciate those that do
i also appreciate beating up a bishop
uh let's win another bishop
okay
it's nice game
i mean it was a tense middle game
but at some point i think f5
it was a beginning of some
unpleasantness for black just with the
e6 pawn
and then once my pieces found good
squares
there was a lot of pressure i mean a lot
of tension that uh
just went in white's favor
there's a question from earlier i was
going to try and address
oh from cdr siri speaking of being
cautious what advice do you have for
beginners
or returnees who are nervous about
trying to play people online or otb
rather than only playing against bots
i think the way to overcome nerves in
any endeavor
whether it's like chess or
[Music]
like anything in real life is you need
to
just get experience
and sometimes it'll be uncomfortable at
first but you you have to force yourself
to
go outside your comfort zone
is actually the case with like streaming
like i wanted to stream but
there are a lot of
i guess
insecurities and a lot of things that
just made me nervous about starting
but once you you get more experience
then it can be more rewarding so
um
i mean if you usually only play against
bots and you're scared of playing real
humans
uh just treat it as like an experiment
like just
don't don't put any pressure on yourself
just
just start games against humans and see
how it goes and if you lose i mean
that's part of the game
[Music]
the master has lost more games than the
beginner has ever played
so sometimes you need to shift your
mindset too
and have a slightly healthier approach
rather than being
result focused
try and be learning focused
there's another quote
every grand master was once a noob
which hopefully will inspire the the
news out there
you have to start somewhere
also welcome back to kyogen
good to see you
okay i'll play my usual thing
never played this opponent before
this is my pet line pawn
a6 and there's a lot of moves in this
position
there's a vienna there's ragosan there's
semi-slav
there's normal queens gambit decline
there's nike bd7
terrace
um
[Music]
i think i encountered this like once in
a collegiate event
um
i don't think it was this position
so i think i'll just play bishop b4 here
and this should be an improved vergosen
because white doesn't have a3
also sometimes in rogozin white will
play queen a4 check to provoke this move
so this bishop's very solid here
no probably castling
i don't think a4 was a blunder but
probably uh
like already some inaccuracy
i'm considering b6
let's develop normally
yeah there's only so much i can do to
punish this move
okay 27 looks
actually queen e7 i have to calculate
c5 also
possible
if c5 actually looks nicer
and this is a case where the spawn would
really like to go backwards
so now i think the plans to play knight
c6
and then pressure d4
also some potential of knight a5
trying to win
the pawn on c4
every grand master was once a sleeping
genius
every grandmaster was also once a baby
okay what to do
it looks
almost like very unstable for white
i still don't know if i can win anything
take on d4 take on c4 the queen lands
here
knight a5 there's queen a2
[Music]
i think i just played bishop b7
just improve
eventually get the rook to c8
and keep all the tension
there's a question what's your favorite
opening for white
uh most people know this who watch me
regularly is a london opening
but recently i've i've been trying to
experiment more
i actually like getting
like fresh positions
where there is more to learn from
i've been playing e4 more
more often at least recently as well
okay so white relieved all the pawn
tension
and now i'm left with two pawns
controlling
a decent amount of space
white setup is a little bit passive
the light does have a clear target eric
in his last video if you're watching
this it's possible i'm live on twitch
right now
i am live
also live
also alive
i want to play knight a5
95 queen a2
uh maybe i can play queen e7
[Music]
because the point can't be taken
[Music]
someone purchased oh no hey my queens go
chessboard t-shirt for 22.95
yeah we do still have the merch command
i was wrapping the merch in the most
recent youtube video
i i did some kind of magic trick halfway
through the video
i think usually the john major
subbing for three months
thank you vandercal
happy 22 months
oh sticky says i tried clapping but my
shirt didn't change
yeah the first step is to order your
merch
shop.iamrosen.com
okay so the point of queen e7 i wanted
to get off the defile of the rook and
if white takes i take take and then the
queen's aligned with my bishop i'll have
knight
oh i didn't calculate this fully knight
e4 there is queen c4
um
i have to go for it now
i messed this up a little bit
knight d4 queen c4
i guess i could take on f3
wait a minute
there's also d2
i'm gonna be down the pawn so i'm
looking for compensation
if i take on d2
and i've worked yet as well
[Music]
okay i think i found some
some solution we'll start with knight d4
queen c4 i take
and white will actually have a choice
between pawn or bishop takes
so my trade
and the point now is to play queen f6
i'm not thrilled with this
but at least i'm hitting a few pawns
anything better there's rook b8
i'll start with queen f6
so i'm down the pawn but the king is a
bit more exposed
there's some pawn weaknesses
there is a line where light wins the b
pawn and then i
i can choose between rook b8 or queen f3
yeah we're simplifying pretty quickly
so
rook b8 there's queen d4
[Music]
that still probably makes sense
queen d6 takes takes
yeah this looks fine
that's still very much a fight
the goal is to eventually get a rook to
g6
i have to start thinking about rook
lifting
i'm down about a minute
yeah so the b pawns defended
now it's extra defended
maybe a5
a5 there's queen e4 and queen g4
[Music]
so queen e4 queen g4
i mean this is a threat there's rook c4
maybe i can play h5 first
gage 5 is the move i want to play anyway
if i make loofed i also have dreams of
checkmating on g2
[Music]
this is also a move i should consider at
some point
probably not something to do too soon
okay now work before
what do you want ideas
hmm
a couple options for whites
i'm still down a minute
i'm still down the pawn to
probably want to play g6 or maybe go for
this plan
because white would have one check
all right like work
maybe a couple checks
i also have this check
ah maybe i check no
i want to check and play rook c8
there's rook d1
let's go for this
it's risky because i don't know if i'm
actually meeting
but yeah there's definitely should be
some concern for whites
i'm not scared of these tracks like rook
d king h7 queen c2 g6
rook g4 is very hard to stop
i guess if this i play rook takes b2
hitting f2 and threatening this
time is leveling out a little bit
yeah so queen e5 and calculation is
queen g4 king f1 rook a4
which looks pretty good
finally up on time
it's john thanks john
oh no my paycheck
hopefully it's a good investment
getting the chessboard oh no my queen
shirt
i actually don't didn't see what white
should do there so now g6
ah interesting
check
f7 is attacked
[Music]
just keep all the tension threatening
this
oh now i'm allowing
maybe you should not have allowed that
check
this move no i don't have
h4
huh
i wasn't sure what to do
[Music]
i think this is a reasonable maneuver
get the rook to f5 where it defends
defends attacks
queen d4 queen e6
hitting this and this
i'm still down the pawn but my king is
safer
and white has more pawn targets
10 scheme
okay i can take on b3
so i keep this defended
might be threatening queen c4
it looks like things are under control
now
start with chuck
welcome back eric your abu dhabi games
were very instructive smile oh thank you
olgi
yeah it's good to be back on twitch
um
tournament was fun
i enjoyed all the games i played but
it's also tiring too so
nice to play some lower pressure chests
yeah the queen found a nice square
defending attacking
can target f2
oh
also defends an attacks
threatening made in two
hey welcome back g space and kavita
g space for for uh 40 months
kavita with ten
not quite mating here
but it's really close
now i'm threatening f2 and e4
but i can't take on e4 just yet
still threatening this
[Music]
now white's resisting
threading made in two
there we go
okay
good fight
i don't think there's much time between
oh there's four games going
okay i'm gonna take a small break
but we can watch the
one of the last games of this round
okay brb
[Music]
[Music]
okay good timing
next round starts in one second
here we go
uh okay i'm gonna turn off pentatonic
someone was asking what's what song
um but this is just a built-in sound
setting on the chess
the moves can generate music
uh i'll play e4 again why not
ah yes the chair gambit a classic in
chess streaming best of luck with the
tournament eric
smile oh thank you hi jinx
okay i'm gonna play this uh funny line
good five
this is a line that
i briefly showed to hannah sace
that's a line i prepared for various
opponents
like danny wrench james canty
it's a way of getting a kind of
non-traditional sicilian
it seems like black has some idea of
what they're doing
there's some a4 move
actually there's no need to play for it
let's just castle
but one idea is to play like a4a5 knight
c4 knight b6
and probably start with d3
wow
i'm trying to internalize what's going
on here
it's already a little bit tricky
like the move the move i want to play is
takes
bishop takes bishop g5 f6
i might have rookie one there
i can start just by taking
oh
d4
i'm looking at
actually looking at queen f3 takes
rookie 197
don't think it works
it's interesting though
could it work
it just looks way too risky
if i play d4
also doesn't look great
i think i should just play rookie one
and not overthink things
yeah rookie 8 is coming
so there's queen f3 here
hitting the d5 pawn
at bishop v6 i could maybe consider c4
um
okay this position looks really really
good now like i wasn't sure for a few
moves what was going on
but
i have the darkspray bishop i have the
bishop hair black has nothing developed
and black is castle though i guess
i think i just have
this move
here takes takes
and then here
otherwise i'm
i'm winning material
and c5 is also hanging
[Music]
oh thank you pitch buckets and orange
crushed
and the evil sloth
i'm trying to like thank everyone who's
been subbing and resubbing
oh
so
defend or attacking defending
[Music]
i don't think i want to take the rook
right away
like rook 81 seems simple enough
yeah this looks really really good
there's a question i think i missed from
earlier i'm trying to find it
oh yeah from face boots
eric have you analyzed your last game at
abu dhabi with the engine
i did i guess i didn't show engine
analysis in the video
but
i guess the spoiler the spoiler for that
is um
the final position
was just completely losing for me
knight c6
okay so i broke d5
i could also
i think now is probably a good time to
take
the king or queen or king takes i rookie
8
if knight takes we just simplify
at this point i'm just looking to
simplify i think queen f4 is a
simplest approach
hello to brix
900
for 33 months
there's a common queen jig's f7 wins
i did not even consider that move
uh
maybe wins for
black probably wins for black
yeah this strategy was just to get
queens off the board
and then
probably to get these things off the
board
maybe rook
i think rook d8 and then double up
no mercy here
yeah resigns also wins for my opponent
but my opponent resigning wins for me
okay
um
yeah this is a line that uh i haven't
had a chance to play too often why are
leather boots good for sneaking because
they are made of hide
ah
very clever
okay playing d stahlberg
playing f6
and we have
this position
um
what do i want to do here c5 is a move
i think c5 is considered to be like the
proper move order
or the the proper way to like respond to
this move order
c3
hmm
this is actually already a new position
for me
i prepared this very briefly for levy
during one of our matches
let's basically reverse grunfeld
i think i'll just play e6
and maybe play in some sort of like
kali's recruit setup
like 97
i play bishop b7 just castle
so with knight g7 i'm ensuring that if
takes i don't have to take with bishop i
can take with knight
and we're getting a slightly slower
position
[Music]
but looks very solid
c4 i'm not too concerned about i think i
just played bishop b7
axiates
this reminds me a little bit of my
second to last round game in abu dhabi
that game we had like um
this pawn tension
against white's catalan
the c4 might be coming soon
some question where my queen wants to be
considering like bishop d6 and queen e7
[Music]
so i don't think e4 can easily be played
it's actually kind of remarkable how
similar this position is
to my game in abu dhabi
because i had almost exactly the same
setup
although in
the abu dhabi game my opponent did not
play e3
he was a bit more active
and the goal is just to keep improving
my rook d8
maybe a6 b5
but i'm in no rush i think i'll play h6
first
just discouraging this idea like e4
knight g5
thank you julie
what's your favorite square on the
chessboard
uh it depends on the position
this position
e4 is a nice wear
might make use of it a bit later
sometimes it's a collection of squares
too
light squares could be
some day in my control
like knight b8 is a interesting idea
i mean there's also knight g8
is white trying to play e4
also i could maybe play e5 here
e5
we trade
and it feels like especially after an
age two
like e5 is probably very timely
because now the knights just misplaced
and uh
expanding nicely
if takes
i think i'll take with knight i was just
trying to calculate this line pawn e4
and then we might trade a bit in the
center
there's actually an idea to play c4 i
don't know how well it works
uc4 here could be interesting
you can also just play knight g6
avoid the nitrate
and white play c4
okay i'm allowing c4 from white
but the point of avoiding the nitrate is
now the knights are a bit clumsy for
white
they kind of step on each other's toes
like to play this move soon
and yeah i'm not gonna be playing fisher
random today
but after the stream i will check the
schedule and
i'll probably do at least one of these
uh qualifier events
okay i think it makes sense to play rook
e8
still very positional
point of virtue it is of c4 i play d4
a pawn is pinned to the queen
that is nice having more space and also
having all the minor pieces on the board
which just means the white is a bit more
cramped
i'm just searching for ways to keep
improving
like maybe this idea
[Music]
oh maybe 95
back there's rook d8
and rook wasn't doing too much on c8
i guess unless maybe c4 was an idea
i'm trying to be patient
yeah c4 is still probably what it wants
to do
[Music]
calculating h4 c4 or h5 c4h4
looks possible
you just bishop b8
ensuring that it's not blocking the rook
potential for the later battery
yeah i was looking at d4 it takes takes
uh it's good to be back i think you're
rust man
i think i'll play ninety five
at 95.93
if i take
we trade
maybe that's the way to go
i'm not sure
watching the stream while i work helps
me focus somehow thanks for the content
as always
i was aware of this move but i thought
uh i mess up
maybe messed up
yeah i thought i had some in between
with my toes
okay i might be a little bit worse here
but it's still interesting
because if if takes i take here first
knight c4 i take on g2
i'm probably 95.
yeah it's a bit more pleasant for white
turn them into a blitz game
on double the pawns at least
knight g4 i have queen c6
and the plan is probably like
a queen e6 i should say queen e6 f5
take with rook
yeah maybe it's still fine for black
of the d file
and so the bishop needs to be improved
wow
fancy move
uh
king g7 probably
yeah if i took the queen the light would
win back the queen and win the pawn
i mean f5 is coming soon
rook d1
ah this move's coming so i've worked e2
[Music]
hitting a2
bishop is just a really bad piece
okay we might trade a pair of rooks
ideally the bishop wants to be on d4
but that's not an easy square to get to
a good move
another five's a threat
king g6
knight d5
maybe it's okay
knight d5 i win e2
yeah taking on these two there's your d8
so it's a tense position
bishop wants to be here
king 2 is probably coming or not
f6 looks so bad
what else
h4
okay
not the happiest of moves
but i do want to take
oh no my rook
takes i fork
um
that's my deals to play c4
taking a risk here
bishop can finally find some life
this act exchange not quite
well maybe i can
calculating king d3 rook f2 or d7
i can't do it here
[Music]
i'm still playing for a win it's risky
though
turning this
there we go
okay
final end game tactic
okay plenty of time too
even though i'm down on time it's uh
easy position to play
okay
well that went to the very end
good game
phew
that was the final game of the round two
so
five out of five
two more rounds left
do you know if there is any engine that
evaluates position sharpness like
looking at how many moves are decent for
a player or similar
not that i know of
but maybe someone in chat can
uh better answer that than me
playing
oh i'm playing
[Music]
is this one of the five pointers
oh i'm playing someone how am i playing
this person ah i'm playing um
one of the four and a half pointers
so i guess the other two five pointers
are playing each other
okay going back to
bread and butter london opening
uh c5 can be met with bishop b5
it's already a little bit unpleasant for
black here
hey let's bring it up king returns
brigham returns too
welcome back
yeah i am back in the u.s as
the first stream in a while
uh okay so king f8
i think king e7 is considered the best
move
and i've looked at this position before
what am i supposed to do
i think some kind of takes in c4
and a6
ah that should be fine
i think this is a
the approach to try and punish black as
much as possible to like open up the
center
and take advantage of the fact that king
is um not castled
so the rook is a bit stuck
yeah i was just looking at this line
so black can't take as the pawns pinned
and queen a5 knight c3
and then if takes i take and hit the
queen
so this looks nice
maybe we'll see bishop d7
knight e4 also a move
i used your absence to finish some
papers for university got nice grades
and smile hey let's go
well maybe now you can celebrate by
enjoying my non-absence
okay i'd like to take
i want to win
estoy muy bien e2
i'm not seeing how to win a pawn
maybe just knight c3
on ic3 we trade
bishop c2
[Music]
i'm taking time like it feels like a
critical position
[Music]
okay yeah i think the bishop is a bit
more useful on c2
because there's a lot of lines where i
do take on e4
so here i am threatening to take and
just win the night pawn is pinned
so there is something like queen g5
or that move
man i want to play
b4 and also maybe take and win the pawn
i mean taking winning the pawn looks
nice
because i'll be attacking the knight
the bishop's also a target
uh knight doesn't have too many great
squares
if bishop five i can take on g7
there's a question why i didn't take and
take on d5
um
[Music]
i was considering it i think
ah bishop takes maybe i didn't consider
that
i was looking at knight takes but
i should have considered bishop takes
anyway uh we got something similar
i could take the knight here
but that does open the file for the rook
but are there any other options
uh yeah let's take
the knight someday wants to come to d5
or e4
yeah we can analyze after the game
[Music]
all right so 94
bishop's attacked
actually 94 has two threats
and i need to take the bishop and also
check and then win the pawn
so i think white's winning more material
here
thank you antoine antoine
oh pabziski asking long time no see
where were you
yeah i was in abu dhabi um i wasn't
active on twitch but i was very active
on youtube
i recapped every game
i played in the abu dhabi masters
so probably the coming days i'll be more
active on twitch
and i'll try and stay active on youtube
as well
actually i have some cool youtube videos
coming up
which will maybe include this whole
tournament
some nice content so far
okay that was feel good game
opponent walked into
yeah this london line
i mean after a q7 i think it's just like
plus point four for white
plus point five
king f8
a little bit better for white
so here
yeah bishop d7 is one of the top moves
i looked at this move after which it
just leads to trades
i guess this is also good for whites
ah cause my queen defends the bishop so
i could take
yeah there's a lot of ways to be better
how many people have been watching for
the full tournament
okay playing
fatima
i'll play my usual stuff
oh i could repeat the same opening as
earlier
yeah earlier my opponent played
c3 here we see c4 interesting
i will admit i'm already out of book
but this looks fine because if queen
takes i i play this
my takes i play the greetings from the
chessboards on the chicago lakefront
oh nice
thank you houston booth
um
i think e5 is a principled move i'm just
not sure
what's going to happen after knight of
three
ah there's a funny idea
i think i played d4 regardless
yeah this is kind of like a reverse
green
but usually in the greenfield there's a
trait on c6
so it's to my benefit that i haven't
played knight c6 yet
uh the knight gets a little bit kicked
around
yeah if knight three i was going to play
d4 and 95.85 check
i think just a6 here
some queen a4 idea
bishop d7
knight c3 i play d4
and there's a funny line queen a4 takes
takes and then takes
would be down the exchange but have a
lot of pawns
i mean i think bishop d7 is a simpler
approach after queen a4
thanks a lot for all the great content
got me back to playing chess smile oh
nice to hear
thank you palms
yeah probably d4 here
i mean i already like the position
[Music]
i just want to maximize
the advantage
i'm taking on a3
[Music]
i think d4 closes things down a little
bit but
yeah it leaves the knight really awkward
just complete
development bishop will probably come
here
it might be worth playing h6 at some
point
although
i mean if it wants to play bishop g5 and
take on f6
i'm probably happy to allow it
good to see you back eric
good to see you too awkward night
it's also good to be back
i think streaming is one way to
help overcome jet lag
like it forces me to be awake
b3
okay
oh castle
yeah probably now h6
bishop about five
and bishop five first
nothing too special just developing
maybe at some point i could play e4
get the center pawns rolling
queen d7
there's this maneuver too knight g7 to
c5
welcome back eric
oh thank you malcolm reynolds
hooray for friendship
hooray
hey it's kung fu chess
i took a small break from kung fu chess
during my serious classical chess
tournament
i'm thinking queen b6 here
it's just a way to get off the d8 square
it discourages e3
if i play z3 i take and then take
and it frees d8 for one of the rooks
i'm not sure if i want to set up like
rook e8 and d8 or
c8 and d8
it might depend what white does
hmm
knight d3 may be coming
i mean maybe now e4
just completely restrict the knights
and yeah now the rooks want to
definitely come to the center files
support the pawns
and white's just really cramped here
yeah both pawns are defended and
can be reinforced multiple times
like it is sometimes dangerous to like
overextend like this
so there's so much support
wow thank you double b
24 months
so always have to keep in mind the pawn
bushes
but let's start with
rook d8
time is good position is good
i think there was a case another game
where um i had the space advantage
and usually the space advantage is
nicest when
all the minor pieces are on the board
it's just so hard for the pieces to find
activity as white
i think white's one active plan is a3 b4
i was going to say which should be
stopped by a5
king h1 okay i'll play rook e8
so king h1 gets off the diagonal
but also leaves f2 a little bit more
vulnerable like maybe i could play
knight g4 d3
i'm also envisioning
like eventually
greetings from hilversum the netherlands
go eric quack quack
thank you amno
[Music]
i don't think i've been to hilversum
the towns in the netherlands i've been
to were
oh man
we're amsterdam of course
kinderdyke
leiden
[Music]
cheveningen
not sure if i'm pronouncing that
correctly
nice country
okay 25
so white sat upon for now the the file
i guess the knight can come here
can i be more greedy probably not
play queen c2
things are still very controlled
my b5 might come soon
i think the position still requires some
patience
still some more improving too
queen
queen g7
getting off the file of the rook
if knight b6 i play queen e6
there's some idea to play bishop h3
because if ever white takes i take and
then have knight g4
and the idea would be to
get a queen to h5 and then g4
maybe in combination with a rook lift
like rook d5 looks really attractive
but
maybe i start with this move
and then yeah then this this takes and
then eventually meet
welcome back eric
welcome back
i like your spelling of bach
bishop c5
i'm not rushing
make sure the pawn's defended
rook d5 is probably my next move
i gotta get some rook lifting in
bishop a7
still avoiding trades
also thank you dr dark francis
okay white really wants to trade with me
it's probably time to trade
but it's also time to rook lift
because once work h5 happens it's really
hard to stop takes in queen h3
uh
yeah i don't see how white's defending
there's a question from mr knight why
didn't you take
pawn with a bishop
not sure what moment
i can go back after the game
[Music]
ma purchase do you even rock lift bro
muscle tank top for 30 dollars
yeah if only i could clap my hands
to change into a rook lift tank top
it happened in the most recent youtube
video
okay so this was the power of the rook
lift
the queen enters a game
[Music]
uh this wins a queen
opponent wants a draw
but i want a free queen
the sniper bishop
no mercy here
oh no opponent's queen
oh yes
back to swag master
okay so the the main
goal is just not get back right now
but as long as my rook stays on the back
rank
things are pretty good
bishop e3 incoming
my opponent could play bishop d2 and say
oh no my knight
and then i would get made it if i take
it
i believe this is what the kids call a
bra moment
bruh
oh no my rook oh no
someone call an ambulance
but not for me
i guess i had bishop a3 immediately i
was thinking i would deflect the knight
to get bishop e3
anyway uh that was a fun game
thanks for the game
if you just tuned in i have a lot of fun
games
sorry for the spoiler
but i'll probably put the whole thing on
youtube
either on the main channel or extra
channel
so be sure to
subscribe on youtube